well thank you guys so much for doing
this I am horrible with videos as you
can tell because everyone in the office
was just here that's a small company
then we do the only have seven of us
seven or eight of us I love to say I'm a
fan oh thank you so much we love you
guys too we were we all watched ass on
the internet on loud actually and then
went around and rated which of us would
have been in it so it was good okay well
kind of to start things off I was
wondering if you guys you found your uno
cards I'm pretty psyched um i have my
own deck of cards so pretty much the
only game i could come up with with
everyone's help i'm gonna hold up a card
you guys are gonna hold up a card
whoever is the lowest value takes a
drink okay he doesn't drink bad away so
there's been me and Mike that's okay i
was when i first thought of this I was
like wait maybe they don't drink and
then I'll just look like this crazy beer
person what's the guy in the elevator
thought so is six of us that oz is one
of us would a drink so but they're only
three of you here so that listened our
odds considerably that's true oh that's
awesome you got two out of three all
right are you guys the deck might okay
what if it's like a reverse card I guess
that too I don't know cuz I took all my
like flush cards out so we're just gonna
then just pull it up just keep going
till you get a number sounds good evan
Davis so how long is this game gonna go
for ya too long Oh we'll see how many
shots you guys get in now before we get
to the interview I know I don't want
that to happen so right before then okay
let's go get their dick so ready I'm
ready all right ovary 21 all right guys
what's yours tonight Sammy nine ha
Cheers all right all right what is it
there what's that for too early for this
okay
yes it's better than one okay you ready
all right ready three two one oh damn
alright for all right okay oh yeah
you're gonna be you're gonna be waste
after my two beers yep all right three
two one did you know okay s'pore we got
it too yes okay you're gonna need some
more beers in there what we're doing
here I'm not to take it away from the
co-workers that I gave it to okay three
two one oh sorry guys darling we don't
have to do too many more all right all
right keep it going three two one Wow
you rigged your dick I to put all the
tall numbers on the top and then just
laughed no yeah all right last one all
right last one sounds like a plan okay
okay three two one oh wow hard you know
that that's the biggest car okay you
know what I'll just I got this one guys
the last card in the deck sounds good
alright cool well thank you guys so much
for doing this with me i really
appreciated no Brad Allen has been
talking about you guys for a while so
this is pretty cool this was original so
I'm liking the interview already I tried
I was pretty there's not a lot of people
in the office so usually share it so I'm
alloys one he's like let's bring beer
everyone that's awesome yeah but you
know just kind of start off I was
wondering if you guys would just tell me
a little bit about how this all got
started like the founding ideas behind
it and how its kind of grown since then
cool Wow
but my parents had sex and after that
you know we kind of moved on so you
don't want the very beginning you know
no you just you go wherever you want to
start okay you know 2007 in a manual we
went to my dad's house he doesn't Macon
Georgia with like an hour outside of
Atlanta and we made a little video for
fun we just put it on you put it on
facebook this is before the like button
so you know it was has a long long so we
put the video up into something random
and silly and it got a lot of comments
and then we're like hey cam and Cena
Hughes told amenities that bring back
your camera from home and so then we
started putting like little videos up on
facebook and people really like them and
then cam and Amanda came up with the
idea like hey let's turn this into a
business and we kind of just my boy ever
since awesome from there and it
officially came business what Marx 17th
of 2009 11pm not March begin to march
Wow congratulations guys were you all
because there's so many of you were you
all originally involved or did it start
with kind of the core of three people
and then just grow from there it started
with a core three no I'm oh yeah what
infotainment launch it was all six of us
we all came together and it was we're
all here it wasn't like we it was like
we recruited members we're all friends
we've all known each other forever so
that's why the chemistry so good we met
in college there's a lot of chemistry
happening in all the videos yes well how
did you all kind of meet each other well
me and wrong same beginning me okay
you're probably get hit me and micah
best friends since sixth grade he just
wanted you to start with that point me
me and chairs are brothers mm-hmm older
brother so that's the connection with us
three okay I met the other three in
college well into atlanta and then he
moved to Atlanta for college Chaz and I
moved in Florida to Atlanta as well and
08 and that's how we all came to does
came to
just said let's do this thing it's none
banwait possible to I never thought that
once don't not direction like don't even
worry yeah that's why we think it works
so good because I don't think any of us
pictured is doing what we're doing right
now like not at all because I went to
school for audio tailings going he went
to school for motion graphics Michael to
school for everything but that's why I
works out so well you know most time
when you put groups together never last
so this is organic and you know this is
natural so have you all graduated from
school now yes we're okay neat so is
this are you all able to support
yourself on this business or is everyone
kind of in different spots right now
yeah we all quit our day jobs we oh
that's really exciting I also quit my
night job as a stripper we're sure
you'll do it that we do you know don't
get in free lance with that or anything
yeah no not anymore oh you know it's the
real deal yeah you know dormtainment
support smile fortunately when was that
moment where you guys kind of thought
like wow this can really be a business
mm-hmm well honestly when we first
started we had a business plan will meet
when we decided that we're going to make
this if we're going to take the stage so
we had a business plan we knew that we
wanted we emulated ourselves after like
a college humor we want to be like them
we want to have a website where people
come to upload where we put our original
content on so we kind of already had a
business format that we wanted to be
like already so I mean beginning I would
say but we didn't know how big it was
going to be on till probably a year and
after some of our videos went viral and
we were like wow I think we might have
kind of noticed it at the wheat in 09 in
November bone man we get our first live
show we never planned on doing
anything really and oh we got invited to
host a variety show it georgia state
university it was like a bit like a big
talent show me everybody hosted and we
think it will be a small show but it was
like 800 900 people there and we ended
up doing really well and after that our
numbers kind of started moving after
that because people started talking in
the common word started spreading after
that and a lot of people don't know this
is our second channel our first channel
got deleted so that was two years of
work just wiped out by over a hundred
videos may be gone how did that happen
he he explains that the best it was just
a false flagging a lot of a Content that
was because the Sun get deleted off our
channel out of nowhere and then we had
our first strike I don't know where one
day and yeah our channel was done
there's no one to talk to it wasn't like
a drunk friend had come over and get all
your computer and you didn't know it
okay that's a little bit better yeah
that happened i think we all be in jail
they would have made it youtube being
deleted kind of opened up every single
door that we had opened up from this
like a thousand a year we have over 30
million views and we saw asked that
account almost 2,000 subscribers so it
really was a blessing in disguise pretty
much pretty much what it was did it did
you feel like it just kind of gave you a
clean slate to start over yeah
definitely what were some of the things
that you've learned along the way from
that first channel that you're able to
kind of like move fast in this next one
well we kind of learned that format and
what we want to do because i think i
first channels all over the place you
had vlogs we had videos in front of the
camera we had all types of stuff but now
with this channel we know our skits in
our music our bread and butter and
that's what people want from us so
that's all we give them so i'm gonna hit
what is your creative process kind of
like does everyone have their own little
niche or do you all switch off the
directors hat and editing all the time
well we do everything in-house from the
idea riding and shooting it
color correcting it audio everything so
usually it starts out like we could be
out we see something funny and we like
that be funny if Fabio funny skit and it
will brainstorm and write it out then
we'll shoot collect for example like
outs I'll grind out past the mall and
I'll run past the up valet parking and I
said valley man run full speed like full
speed all right and I like why like why
they running so fast out why they have
to have some type of valet boot campers
on man as soon as I said it I put that
in my phone I brought it to the guys we
all sat down and wrote it and we just
shot the skip those really comes from
just yeah real life situations when I
guess that's just sitting here cut out
five out of six of us live together we
share we share an apartment so we're
always talking we're always watching
things and we're always coming up with
ideas from those things that we watch
and see so just just us being friends
right I know you and your friends Potter
sit out and like you know would be funny
or that's so funny and what we find
funding is what we out and hope
thankfully other people find it funny
too we'll meet yeah my friends and I
talk about animal videos so you guys a
little bit more sophisticated humor
which is good those are funny too though
they are wonderful yes do you guys have
a favorite video I think everyone is so
hard as it's rough how's that stuff
fester alright so like if someone came
up to you and you wanted to show them
like one video like you have only had to
show them one video like which one do
you think you would want to show them
because it depends on the person wait I
think I think one video and everyone
would like that everybody knows what
we're doing is its catch a predator we
did a parody today and uh one everyone
knows that that show and it's already
funny with in itself to show us up but
we did a parody to it and everyone
killed their characters everyone had a
part and I feel like that video anyone
can relate to so I feel like I would
probably show them they're gonna take
Alan okay cool yeah how much are you
guys gonna pick one no I would probably
if I just want to make them laugh just
laugh I would pick thats in which shows
that's what the everyone's going to
laugh at someone getting the try it with
a little punks ohh really i think if uh
if a woman was to ask me I probably show
her relationship screams very relatable
you know people everybody knows my
relationships laughing I don't think
that that would be a good one to the
show too I think I'm almost torn between
the ass on the Internet one and my
roommate having sex both so funny and so
good laughs I mean that was a lot of
work so I love that video is I mean how
did you guys expect that one to take off
so much because it's I would say it's
more of your best known videos well it
didn't take off as much as we thought it
would sad to say that we drop other
videos that we didn't expect to take off
this much but before we drop this and we
were like this has to go this has to
take off so we put a lot of time we've
been making the album over a year now
and we just released it like three weeks
ago so we put a lot of time we knew this
was going to be our first single like
last year and we knew how the concept be
one of the concept of beep in four
months now so when we put all this work
behind booking all these people getting
on the director and the camera and
everything like that we were like this
has to go so it did good for you know I
mean it's been a little over to Lisa
list it's still going but you know we
yeah but we expected we wanted a sign
gunman style numbers will work on that
yeah we released want to get to a
million so we or microlight is like
right here and we just reach in and we
just our goal was to get it get it to a
million with week but that didn't happen
but you know hopefully by the end of
January it should be there you guys had
so many intricate little details that
like involve the social media what do
you think the most important element of
social media has been for you personally
in this group I mean I think that's our
greatest outlet of promotion so on
facebook and twitter is this key to us
promoting every sunday every Sunday we
will rather fans up they have like a DG
Sunday
at 7pm everyone's ready for it if we
don't drop a video that day for some
reason they're just gonna free where's
the video that I've been waiting all
week for this so i think it's the
important thing there so stay in touch
with your fan base in iraq tops on it is
a social medias key social medias help
us with consistency i'm definitely about
consensus because you know like
especially like the hashtag you know you
can hashtag and it's sunday or hashtag
whatever skid we have it is helps us
with our consistency when it comes down
to our gifts the notes for our sessions
we drop a new video every Sunday forces
are sustained on it okay I I personally
am interested to know how did you choose
the right people to be featured in us in
the internet on the internet how can one
be an ass on the Internet is what I want
to know basically how I came about in
avoid our own videos we ask anyone who
wants to be in a video girl any girl I
was gonna send us an email submission
with a picture your age and where you're
from where you live so we got over 200
submissions we had to go through that
filter and skype some of these people
make sure they're real before we give
out our address and everything you
didn't 150 year old men coming to your
door actually this is awkward we
ciphered through it and we pick took you
want we wanted all sizes all races or
anybody it was how it was a lot of work
it's like it took a good three days to
go through everything but that's how we
got them all and some of them was out
some of our friends a lot of them were
fans and a lot of them are friends so
you know a lot of a lot of people always
want to be in our video so I feel like
this opportunity for them and we had one
girl drive all the way from South
Carolina yeah two hours so you know the
fans came through that's awesome do you
have any crazy fans stories well we just
can't me Rome my brothers came from
bahamas I'm half Bahamian air we are
celebrities they were no hay bum rush
they want pictures they really date I
really feel like a celebrity like
I honestly feel that's how celebrities
feel on everyday basis so that's the
crazy we were actually in a little party
they have down there you know
everybody's just dancing having fun and
there's a guy like I've never been
paparazzi before us and then there's a
guy like he first you know he introduced
himself and you know he's like we love
you I love your video yeah no pension no
problem thank you for watching and then
I'm just chillin then he I see him in
the distance like five feet when he's
snapping pictures of me later Cindy
Smith a pitcher can its method to wait a
little bit and he going he get a back
angle of bees kind of kind of weird but
I mean is what it is but not crazy we're
like we have people stalking us yet not
yet that we know of usually I know they
might be sneaky starters well what are
your future plans for the channel what
are you guys kind of working on now well
um right now we are we are working on
signing to a new network route you know
like the group's not makers but yeah
company like that yeah okay we're we're
looking to sign with you network and I
we're working on getting our TV show up
trying to work with China's fat and
album music merchandise more scoop more
Skills definitely more Skills we are
definitely trying to up our game in 2013
and become even bigger grow our numbers
and just keep being consistent with what
we're doing do you guys want to stay in
the Atlanta area or would you consider
coming to the west coast no no wow the
unison okay how people are advising us
to stay in Atlanta but we really want to
go to the west coast we really love LA
and when he was talking about networks
we were talking about like TV networks
to try to get a show wit we're trying to
get shine way to deal with washer that's
amazing it's to be yeah so and say we
can even skip TV and go straight to a
movie I mean as possible so we're
anything I mean we write scripts all the
time have ideas all we need is the right
people so
we're talking we're trying to get there
right now so next time we can do our
drinking game in person no that's very
exciting hopefully what do you hope that
people take away from your videos and
your channel and all your work well for
me like when people just say that they
are inspired to create Vanessa I want to
best one of the biggest things I mean
because I like if we can leave a legacy
bond and that would be that would be
great of course we want to do our thing
but for people to come up say you
inspire me to write or you inspire me to
be creative no matter what it is or just
to keep going like that's for me I love
when the fans email to say they were
depressed or having a bad day and I'll
videos help them through it so stuff
like that motivates me and wants making
when I left that and to kind of add on
to a room set but I'm to make sure like
when people see what we do it doesn't
take much to be creative you can have no
money and still make something really
great and that's why I feel like we we
show the world that hey we're six broke
college guys all we are friends we have
one camera and just do and we have
thousands of fans who come and watch us
every day and you can do it as well and
you're like we send that message to
everyone so that's that's the biggest
thing i think that's awesome you know
that's it for most of my questions do
you guys have anything you want to add
do you want people to know or any
questions you have about this why don't
let them know that we drop the album
it's a great album is number one in the
comedy section on itunes they hit the
Billboard charts at number 31 number
three in comedy and some who in R&B so
it's only 499 and supported it it is
great and we'll have more music videos
to follow and just you know kind of pick
it back up what he say it's only 499 we
actually had to buy the app we didn't
need him and we also drop a video every
Sunday at seven but we won't have one
this sunday because of the holiday so
don't kill us
noted okay well yeah do you guys have
new year's plans well I just we just got
back in town yesterday so now we're
going through the whole process defining
what was out there for us to do I say
just stay home and be safe there's my
baby oh yeah you know that the world
didn't end in 2012 yeah oh yeah that
sounds good yeah yeah would you they
didn't put in leap years so it might
just be one year back yes sir yes sir
but they were wrong well thank you guys
so much for doing this with me I really
appreciate it thank you for accidents do
we love the site so oh thank you well
yeah next time you guys are in LA we
would love to meet up with you oh I got
your numbers are definitely will email
so I'll email you that sounds good okay
awesome well you guys have a great day
you turn it's nice meeting those nice
meeting you guys thank you bye
you